good morning Hank it's Wednesday so last
week was one of the worst weeks of my
life Henry was really super sick and we
were very scared and also he was crying
all night every night so we were staying
up all night and it was just misery plus
I was worried the project for awesome
wouldn't raise any money in the website
would break and it would be a total
failure and all of nerdfighteria would
hate us and exile us to the island of
elba like you know how the world's
largest ball of stamps is in Omaha
Nebraska well last week it felt like the
world's largest ball of sock was here at
my house but then things started to
change first and most importantly Henry
got better then the project for awesome
generated more than three thousand p4a
videos and raised more than 135 thousand
dollars it probably raised much more
than that but that's how much we can
confirm I mean Hank I'm pretty sure that
135 thousand dollars is a lot of money
although admittedly I am NOT a
mathematician I have an idea I'm calling
Brotherhood 2.0 resident mathematician
and state representative elect Daniel
Biss so here's what I want to ask today
in your opinion as a professional
mathematician who has been published in
the annals of mathematics is $135,000 a
lot of money yes we did it so we raised
a lot of money and then then then I was
on Jeopardy so I made of Awesome
nerdfighter librarian named Julia Carlos
was on Jeopardy yesterday and she did
not know the question for Final Jeopardy
so calmly and confidently she wrote on
her little tablet who is John Green as a
subtle shout-out to nerdfighteria which
in-turn Hank led to Alex Trebek uttering
the immortal words John Green that's
gonna cost you
Julia Carles I'm sorry that you lost on
Jeopardy but thank you for making my
life and the good news is you win the
non-existent nerdfighter prize of the
day which isn't nothing actually it is
nothing nerdfighters thank you for
making p4a videos for donating for
commenting for making Alex Trebek say my
name on television Hank my week has
taken such a turn that I can only share
with you my happy dance as coached by
wheezy waiter
keep dancing don't stop
[Music]
and now for my grand finale a human
state so Hank on December 26th we're
gonna draw the Raffles I gotta finish my
zombie apocalypse novella but I'm on it
Hank
I will not see you on Friday because
it's Christmas Eve but have a wonderful
holiday and I will see you again on
Monday